why does it hurt so much to lose faith
in god
yeah i would say that
the seeking of god let's say that
is an obsession for me and has been
since i was young
i i really feel that i'm a
deep deep deeply
like
committed
to
finding answers in life and there's some
answers that i don't think there's an
answer to and i'm also very ocd by
nature so i just don't give up to that
i'm like well there must be somewhere in
tibet there's some teacher or there's
there's somebody out there that has the
answer
or maybe it's yet to be found i'm going
to find it
i'm really my life has come been to date
probably unhealthily committed to
finding answers about
god or the lack thereof
and um
mortality
it's all i sing about it's all our
records have been about
who do you think is god have you ever
gotten a glimpse
you know i will say the closest i feel
like i have been to experiencing
god is uh and this sounds so
uh
maybe i don't know
i don't know how it sounds but it's
through ayahuasca for me
that's that's my honest answer for you i
feel like
i had pretty much given up all hope of
there being anything greater than
you know
us
being
you know evolving and being here and
then dying and you're gone and that's it
and nothingness and from nothingness we
came and nothingness we go
to where i am now which is there are
answers
to be found i don't know them like i
don't know what god looks like or if god
is anything to do with the word god in
the way that we say it
but i do believe
pretty fervently that there is more to
be
uh found
is it motion sensor or no i don't know
what that was look like they've all died
actually
do you know which one is it is it this
one
i just take it out right here
i'm gonna take it out
do you wanna hold this chair
see if i can't get it like this yeah
yeah
how many people does it take to what is
that on school light bulbs
it was hot too like i was doing like the
two-finger like technique yeah
i'm glad you survived that thanks
that'd be pretty ironic if we're talking
about mortality and then this would be
it for you
you